do you know what the 1% earners in
America make on average year yes 867,000
year
nope 400,000 yeah if you look it up
right now it's 400,000 think about that
funny thing is I looked it up this
morning actually for a completely
different reason is that true no it's
important it's an important topic for me
that's why I'm asking did you do you
know if you possibly I want to know if
I'm right I don't have the right source
do you think well not that do you think
um you think you might have done New
York uh I don't know because I think
it's just like here I'm just gonna go to
it right so like top 1% all right here's
the 1% on CNN money and I've looked at a
bunch they've got this little cute
calculator right when you go to 1% it's
four hundred thousand you know it's
funny everybody who's listening right
now and I know my audience and I know
your audience right all right at least
somewhat right I don't think they think
it's you even think about where you're
like even like even I didn't think I
thought it was higher like 1% the one
you're the one percent best in the
number one market in the world for
capitalism and it's four hundred
thousand I think of a lot of people
listening we're grounded in that number
instead of a million instead of more
than that that they would become more
patient I think that we're selling them
that they need to make 10 million a bill
the kids are gonna build a billion
dollar company because of Facebook well
it's I agree and so a lot of people
think oh I got an idea I need venture
capital would yes this is the wrong
approach and and you didn't do that
approach of no it's an internet probably
obviously the denry's but raise venture
capital for a wine store no so so it's
just they built up and you even
mentioned in the book cash is king
yes
my friends we need to 100% step back and
understand entrepreneurship is
individual first and foremost but
however we have to understand what
successful entrepreneurship looks like
because there's way too many 20
year-olds heck there's way too many 40
50 and 60 year-olds that think they have
to make a million a year to be
successful